in the alternate history of homefront
revolution America is on its knees
utterly dominated by a foreign invader
its landmarks destroyed its resources
pillaged its people subjugated this
unsettling future makes for an evocative
ambitious premise but the resulting
shooter can't quite live up to that
potential in part because it suffers
from a larger than average number of
mild but persistent technical issues in
the interest of providing a fair and
thorough review we've decided to hold
our final verdict until they've had more
time to test the game on Xbox one and PC
as I've spent the majority of my time
playing on ps4
to be clear homefront never once crashed
on me my safe data was never corrupt my
system never locked up nothing that
drastic however every single time the
game Auto saved which happens constantly
during the campaign the screen would
freeze for a solid two seconds during
several of the more chaotic moments the
framerate struggled to keep up
occasionally slowing all the way to a
sputter more than once all the audio
besides the characters dialogue cut out
entirely and along the way I noticed
dozens of smaller issues like my
character's hand clipping through a door
every time a particular animation played
none of these issues rendered the game
unplayable in fact I was generally able
to look past these issues and appreciate
everything homefront does right it's
strongly story driven single-player
campaign for example manages to feel
rich substantial and varied with only a
handful of tedious fetch quests padding
out the proceedings I was constantly
thrown into new areas that not only
looked fresh but demanded new types of
play as well after starting in a
severely bombed out section of
Philadelphia which hero Ethan Brady
seeks to liberate from the fictional
Korean People's Army I eventually ended
up in a sunny tree-lined neighborhood of
foggy wasteland filled with toxic gas at
a massive Arkham City style prison the
narrative guiding you through all these
areas is predictable and borderline
jingoistic with points but the shooting
mechanics are punchy and enjoyable in a
very far cry kinda way every weapon in
your customizable arsenal delivers
impactful hits to leave your enemies
staggered and bleeding granted these bad
guys aren't the brightest Bunch but
they're plenty threatening in large
numbers and they've got like unmanned
tanks and security drones and these
giant attack blimps it's crazy
homefront also offers stealth options
including the ability to distract and
lure enemies with firecrackers for
example but the results were often
inconsistent I was spotted through a
wall more than once and found sprinting
away from an enemy before his awareness
meter fully filled was somehow less
suspicious than crouching in the shadows
just on the edge of his line-of-sight
and once your enemies are alerted ending
the alarm can easily devolve into a
protracted and frustrating process since
hiding spots are rare in certain areas
while the campaign gives you plenty of
ways to use all these tools for better
or worse the completely separate co-op
campaign offers only six missions total
you can replay them at any of three
different difficulty levels but even
then most missions can be completed in
roughly 10 to 15 minutes and unlike the
campaign you can't choose which weapons
and attachments you acquire as you
progress instead you must blindly
purchase a loot crate with random
unlocks so far that's proven frustrating
and pointless but I plan to spend more
time in the co-op campaign as I test
homefront on PC and Xbox check back
later this week to see if the ambitious
premise and robust campaign are enough
to compensate to the game's technical
shortcomings and mixed mechanics